foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they actually love
or create actual amazing relationships
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five you
guys jump in we'll talk about your life
and your money William is going to start
this hour off in Dallas Texas hi William
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve man what's up
uh yeah I got a question about a prenup
um I've listened to a lot of your clips
some of them kind of Applied some of
them didn't but uh basically there's a
I own a business and have done well on
some properties and there's a definitely
a large gap between me and my fiance
what's your net worth
uh net worth
um
property values are probably like 1.4 I
only have 230 in debt on those uh
uh and then in cash I probably got like
750. what's your business worth
uh seven mil okay
so your 10 million dollar guy
and uh she has a more traditional normal
net worth she's not a freak like you
I guess not no you're a good freak
though I like you so it's good you're
the right kind of freak man I'm just
saying all right yes I would I would get
a prenup
okay okay I don't believe in prenups
I tell 99 of people not to get them the
only time in 30 years of coaching that
I've run into a situation where I wished
someone had had a prenup was where there
was a vast disparity
between the two people getting married
and 99 of the time the problem doesn't
end up being with the two people
it's not your fiance it's weird dad gum
people in her family
that come out of the woodwork and screw
up everything and if she can just hold
up the hand and go nope can't I gotta
prenup I don't have I got nothing to say
about that I got nothing because all of
a sudden they're like
little JoJo married William yeah let's
go visit you know I mean this is what
you know what I'm saying yeah I do yeah
and that's uh and and bless your heart
your fiance didn't see it coming because
she did not think crazy was going to
manifest itself that way in her extended
friends or family and so that and it
ends up screwing up y'all's relationship
the prenup actually assists the
relationship in this case so but for
everyone else I just say no if you have
to have a prenup to protect protect your
four dollars then you don't need to get
married
correct now what happens if
you know your fiance your girlfriend
what does she think about it
so that's an issue
um you know she thinks that I you know
quote love my money more than her
um she's not thrilled or at least at the
beginning wasn't thrilled and so
um I basically you know because in Texas
you're you know
everything is common you know property
once you get married and so then it all
gets split
um so I had pretty much what I had
structured was you know separating
everything and then maybe giving her
like
clever you were married if we were to
anything were to happen you know she
would get a certain amount per year you
know so I guess my next question would
be I would not do that
um and I would explain to her that this
is uh as much for her benefit it is as
yours because of what I just described a
few minutes ago
this gives her this releases her anyone
no one of your friends
are going to be suspicious that she
married a gold digger none of your
family is going to think that she has
bad motives this helps her
and if you want to restructure or do
away with the prenup at any point in
your life you can do that
okay you can just go back into the
attorney the two of you sit down and go
you know what I'm gonna release five
million dollars over here
well if you do a set thing on the number
of years the the year that that kicks in
or actually accidentally coincide to the
roughest year in your marriage
right and you will have that roughest
year you know that so I mean why
complicate it that's true yeah and you
can go in and change it anytime but I
don't I I think I like her being Beyond
suspicion with all of your friends and
relatives for that matter her friends
and she also gets to hold up the hand to
her crazies that come along
mm-hmm and go look it's William's stuff
but but and then now having put the
prenup in place that's the legal move
then I would begin to run the
relationship as if you own it all
together
that's the key right there I think
that's the key that makes it all
all good so in other words if I were you
I'm going to talk to my wife before I
make a big business move
so that she's included this is not just
hey this is all my Mountain over here
you have no access you have you don't
get to you don't get to speak about this
yeah that's not what we're saying we're
saying if this if this whole thing hits
the wall you don't get any of this
that's all we're saying but that's
different then you don't get to speak
over it because she you want her to
speak over it proverbs 31 is who can
find a virtuous wife for her worth is
far above rubies the heart of her
husband safely trusts her and he will
have no lack of gain I have made more
money and built more wealth while
listening carefully to my wife who has a
home ec degree
and unbelievable hillbilly wisdom
now let's ask let me ask another
question on your behalf so your business
is worth seven million now the prenup is
only covering the current value not
recovery we cover the ownership of the
business period period oh that's crazy
yeah that's the way I would build it you
can you can wear it that way you don't
have to put a dollar amount on it that's
interesting though because if
they get married and now she's speaking
into the business the business is
growing and she still
is not that I'm not gonna lie
that's a tough one for me okay she is
completely I'll help you she's
completely benefiting if this business
is worth 14 million later instead of 7
million she's going to be eating right
that's right that is right she gets to
fly in that airplane but if something
happens
even the growth is no longer up for yeah
yeah but debate but again he can go back
and re-change that later he can and uh
if he looked up and said look the reason
this business went from 7 million to 25
million is uh she has really contributed
yeah and you can just remove some of the
prenup that is true that is true I
that's true now I'm gonna run it as I'm
gonna run your relationship in your
household and all of your business
decisions as if
she was there when it all began yeah and
this is my child bride wife that we got
married when we were whatever don't say
child baby children's I mean like Sharon
I got married at 22. we were like baby
children and Sam and I too yeah and so
we were little children's children so we
got you know we were both dumber than a
rock and so we grew the whole thing
crashed it and then grew another one
together yeah right so so there's no
question about that she owns it matter
right she technically owns most of it so
but the uh uh but the the the the uh the
exactly I'm gonna I'm gonna run the
relationship in a way that you don't
Lord over her assets her income she
completely participates in those and so
we have an income
from our business
unless we're divorced and then it's not
and then your boy gets it well that's it
I mean it's it's it only is
only comes up if there's a problem right
yeah this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace Hollow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
okay let's clear something up if you
listen to the show for 10 seconds you
know we hate that and some people just
for some reason don't hear that I don't
know they think you need debt and credit
cards to build your credit because you
need a credit score to buy a house right
wrong truth is if you're living a
debt-free lifestyle eventually you won't
have any credit score
so when you're ready to buy a house you
got to find a good lender like Churchill
Mortgage
who can do what's called manual
underwriting and that's where they
personally review your financial history
to approve you for a mortgage like we
did before there was a FICO score we
actually made sure you had a freaking
job and stuff so wow what a concept yeah
so this way you get to avoid the whole
credit score game where you borrow money
to raise your scores so you can borrow
money so you can raise your score so you
can borrow money so you can raise your
scores so you borrow money so you can
raise your score so you borrow money
sounds like fun if you're a bank or a
dog chasing its tail that one too
which are usually dizzy uh no pun
intended it might sound crazy to some
people but the best plan for your
futures avoid debt get a real estate
agent it will help you find a house you
can actually afford get it paid off as
soon as possible and we recommend agents
who are Ramsey trusted these are agents
that are high octane high protein they
didn't get their license last week and
they're not your uncle Charlie who's
guilt-tripping you this is your freaking
house
it's the largest asset you have so you
can buy a house without a credit score
and you can work with an absolute
professional and you need to
ramseysolutions.com agent to get a
Ramsay trusted real estate agent
ramseysolutions.com
agent Nathan in Oklahoma City how are
you
I'm doing well how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up
well just got a question for you so I'm
28 years old and I just hit baby step
seven about seven months ago boom wow
thank you and I'm currently like
rebuilding my emergency and stuff
because I deleted my accounts for being
debt free
and I'm just kind of curious where to go
now because I'm kind of lost with the
whole like where to invest my money
um right now what accounts did you do
hold on what what accounts did you
delete
well not like my checking and my savings
like I cleared them all so I could be
debt free pay off the house and
now that I'm 100 debt free I've got my
six months emergency saved and now I am
investing in my
um well I have two Roth accounts one
through work and then a rough uh Ira
good and then I and then I do uh 10 my
tsp
um
and apart from that
um I'm just you know kind of saving
money and living living life every day
really but I need a goal and my goal is
to get more money but that seems really
kind of boring
honestly I mean just to do it that way
and I'm not 100 sure if that's doing the
right thing
Nathan you're in danger
okay if you're in danger of messing all
this up
gotcha because the fastest way to get
rich is boring
and if you go screwing around with get
rich quick trying to be cool you're
going to lose all of the progress you
have made
and and you got you know one of the
things I ran into when I first started
coaching wealthy people years ago was
they had this latent guilt like I've got
two million dollars but I don't feel
like I'm doing it right
like there must be something
sophisticated these smart people are
doing stuff I don't know how to do and
they're the ones with the two million
dollars and they're doing very
simplistic primitive basic things
and they got wealthy but they you know
they certainly did not buy crypto
right right you know they certainly are
not doing nothing down Tic Tac real
estate
you know they're they're not trying to
get rich quick they're not trying to do
a a double uh a double helix backflip
Family Partnership that they read about
on Instagram
because it's a sure-fired way to lose
your butts what it is you know I mean
come on yeah so just put just slow you
know tortoise The Tortoise and the hair
the hair was the sexy cool one he lost
the race
the tortoise was ugly
and steady
and predictable
and boring
please be boring well now Dave all of us
tortoises don't have to be ugly now
you're done
additional Dave but yeah I know and and
seriously but the uh I mean the the
point being the plan yeah is all all of
your smart friends who are broke but
wear clothes they can't afford drive
cars they can't afford and go on
vacations they can't afford all of your
smart friends will make fun of your
tortoise plane right that's right but
they're the sexy hairs they're the ones
that the the rabbit that's cool they
light all the look you know they they
look like they got it all together and
they got nothing nothing nada
it's almost like got a headache that's
all I got
it's almost like we want there to be
like this secret of the wealthy that
only a few people can get their hands on
and then I really wanted that because
I'm really smart at math and so I knew
if it was complicated and difficult I
could do it that must be it that I would
be able to do it and so just show me the
complicated double backflip barrel of
Fish Hooks yeah I'll get it I'll be able
to do it pride comes right before the
fall right before it nope any any Joe
can do it you just gotta Be steady
boring
what you can do is you can pay very
close attention to your accounts
and just go okay yeah I'm Gonna Be
steady but I'm also going to make sure
that sucker's maximizing that's right
that is not going to be 80d I'm not
gonna take my hand off the wheel hand
off the wheel hand off wheel I'm gonna
drive straight through but I'm gonna be
very diligent and go okay this this
accounts for this this accounts for that
and I'm I and I'm goal oriented and
those are things that you are Nathan
that are very good and obviously
I was being a little bit traumatic to
make sure you got the message but but
you've done very well now I would also
say in his situation we we recommend
everybody work with a smart investor Pro
or somebody with their Investments but a
guy like him really needs that
accountability to not get like oh the
Market's being weird or I feel like my
guy told me about this thing over here I
need to be trying he's not going to
function in fear he's going to make he's
going to make bad decisions out of greed
[Music]
um
that's why I was stopping him on because
I know that guy because I was him yeah
because I because I'm smart I don't this
is too slow you know and and that's
that's about the time you're about to
step on it so just get something on your
shoe Jonathan's in Lexington Kentucky
hey Jonathan what's up
hi Dave thank you guys for taking my
call sure how can we help
um I'm getting my way through these baby
steps and I'm trying to think of ways to
get through faster
um I've also developed my career goals
and educational goals and I just wanted
your opinion
um I have a project car
that I've had for about three years now
I haven't been able to get much done on
it and I'm wondering if I should sell it
um so just wondering what you guys think
I'm not sure but I think in the 30
seconds we've been together you told me
your goals have changed
um we
what
like from the time three years ago when
you bought this car you had a goal of
doing a project car
and I think today you don't have the
same goal you have other goals that are
a priority over the car
yeah I absolutely love this car
um I didn't ask that I just said your
goals have changed
I probably love the car but I don't have
a goal of owning it because I don't even
know what it is yet but I probably like
it
what is it uh
z31 Nissan 350X really
yeah it's pretty yeah
what are you doing what are you supposed
to be doing to it
um well it's pretty solid mechanically
but um ever since I've owned it I've let
people drive in and it's gotten pretty
dinged up and depreciated
um so basically just I wanted to do a
rebuild but I'm trying to pass this debt
it's a body rebuild okay yeah so yeah I
mean I think the car I think the car
served its purpose
I thought I heard you say that in
between all these other things I have
new educational goals I have investment
goals I have these other goals when I
bought the car I didn't have those goals
now I've got some competing goals and
the car is further down on the list did
I hear that that's it your priorities
changed
it went down the list is that right
Jonathan
yeah and also the time and effort it
would take to you know get it done you
know and I'd rather be working on my
educational goal there's your answer I
see what you mean no you now I thought I
heard that in there
there's project car on every corner most
people drive project cars so
yeah uh sell it just because you'd
rather do other things I think this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jade wash all Ramsay personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
Tara is in Houston Texas hi Tara how are
you
hi I'm doing well how are you Dave
better than I deserve what's up
okay so I have been uh working the
program for a while I'm on baby step two
so I'm still paying off some debt
um I am almost 39 years old I've never
had a 401k and the company that I work
for just approached me with that they do
match a hundred percent up to three
percent and then up to six percent they
match uh 50 so my question is I still
have about forty thousand dollars
um in debt to pay but I wasn't sure if I
should go ahead and start putting in the
401K since I'm so far like I've never so
far behind so I feel like I'm going to
be playing catch up and uh since I don't
have anything starting from zero
um so but I don't know if I should take
that money and you start putting it in
now or wait until
my 40 000 is completely paid off so we
get people who call in all the time and
they have done what you want to do
they've just went ahead and started
investing not built their savings not
paid off their debt and then an
emergency comes and suddenly they're
401K becomes their emergency fund that's
thing number one so I'm just going to
give you a couple of thoughts to just
let them sink in on why this is not a
good idea and honestly if you're
following our plan the way we teach is
you pause if you currently investing you
pause take that money in your case you
weren't already so you've got all of
your income at your disposal to pay off
this debt you've got 40K left keep
moving through this and then when the
time comes you're going to be able to
take advantage of that
um how much will you paid off already
I've paid off around probably almost six
thousand dollars six and I could have I
could have six thousand and I could have
done more I haven't I haven't been how
long has that have you been working on
that
about four months
and what do you make
I make my salary is 95 a thousand a year
and I get about twenty thousand twenty
to thirty thousand dollars in bonuses
where is all your money going to
foreign
two car payments is I mean two cars is
where it is why do you have two cars
is it because I went through a divorce
and I had one car payment and I ended up
giving it to my daughter who is 16 and
bought myself a new car oh and that's
how I got in the Trap of two car
payments yes so you have forty thousand
dollars in debt and how much of the 40
is cars
38.
8 and and what do you owe on your car
28 on
monhurst
all right and she's 16.
she's 18 now 18. is she working
she is okay
um all right
um
So
the plan that we teach don't start
investing until you're out of debt
assumes that you're going to lean in and
get out of debt with great focused
intensity that you don't have
right you're playing footsie with this
idea you haven't leaned in and said I'm
selling everything in sight I'm getting
out of debt I'm sick and tired of being
broke I make 90 000 a year I got nothing
I'm 39 I'm scared I'm gonna go get me
some and I'm gonna get my debt cleaned
up yesterday I'm not going out to eat
I'm not going on vacation and please
don't talk to me about a new purse you
are getting out of debt and you you're
not at that level
you're just kind of you're just kind of
intellectually exploring this you've not
emotionally engaged it is that fair
yeah so that's what that's why this
seems that's why this seems appealing to
you
go and jump into the 401K because it
feels like you're going to be in debt
forever and it feels like that because
you're going to be in debt forever
right unless you change
so you can do whatever you want to do
obviously you're a grown-up lady you've
got a great intellect you can do a lot
of things you can go be normal and start
the 401K while you try to limp out of
this debt and keep making these same
mistakes or if you're gonna work our
plan which is you called us so that was
your mistake
because we we love you and we are going
we are going to tell you the truth and
so that's right and you're tripping
right now yeah so uh you know
18 year old is going to save up three
thousand dollars in the next couple
months and buy a car and we're going to
sell her car you're going to sell your
car and we're going to get you out of
debt in a few months probably by
Christmas you're gonna be driving a
couple of five thousand dollar cars and
you'll be debt free build your emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
then save up and get you a little better
car and
um you're 100 debt free but the house at
this point and then you can start
putting by this time next year easily
you'll be putting 15 of your income away
for retirement and if you put fifteen
percent of ninety thousand dollars away
from age 41 to age 65 you will have
several million dollars really if you
keep doing what you're doing now you're
gonna have nothing
except rusted cars with payments on them
we had a girl in my Financial Peace
University class which by the way if you
haven't taken that you need to get
signed up for that choose your age she
had about uh 19 000 left to pay off she
was so worried that she was not going to
have anything in retirement because she
had not started investing right then and
there we walked through the financial
roadmap plan and we walked through we
were able to show her that by the time
she pays off her debt if she just puts
the 15 away she was going to retire with
two million dollars
you'll be a bit more than that and
you'll yeah you'll be out more because I
remember what her income was but yeah
you start saving 15 of 100 Grand and you
do that for over uh 25 years that's
about three million bucks I mean and
that's if you don't get a raise and
you're gonna get raised you've got time
sure you've got time but you don't have
time to keep doing what you've been
doing
because if you keep doing the same thing
over and over again and expecting a
different result
which is embracing car payments because
car payments are a way of life and I
have to have a good car because I'm a
divorcee and I'm scared to death the car
is going to break and I have to have a
good car for my kid because I'm scared
of death my female daughter my daughter
obviously she's female is going to uh
have a breakdown I'm scared and I'm
scared I'm scared and I'm scared and I'm
scared and so I'm paying car payments on
forty thousand dollars worth of cars
while I make 90 and I'm broke
that's what that fear is doing to you
and so and by the way I'm not asking you
and the 18 year old to drive three to
five thousand dollar cars for the rest
of your life I'm asking you for you to
drive them for a chapter in your life so
that you never have to drive them again
I can assure you I did not drive a 5 000
car over here today
quite the contrary I drive whatever I
want these days but I paid a price for
the last 35 years by staying out of debt
and only buying things I could afford
and then I've got the money I hear that
that's the way it works so yeah live
like no one else so later you can live
like no one else uh you're a sharp lady
Tara I appreciate you calling in thank
you for joining us and and uh apologize
for picking on you but just know we it's
because we love you and we want you to
win and um but because
Jade there's something and we just got a
minute for the break but it's very smart
to say this
there you cannot sort of do things that
require you to transform your life if
you want to create transformation
you have to push yourself over to the
edge of extreme
yeah yeah you have to do really whacked
out weird things and then when it swing
when once you've reset your your life
you've reset the grooves in your brain
your habit patterns your spiritual
beliefs once you've reset those things
by doing the extreme then you can do
something less extreme much less extreme
and still stay on track but you know you
in other words if you're gonna if you're
350 400 pounds and you want to lose
weight you have to shock your system by
doing extreme things yeah you throw out
all the cupcakes you throw out all the
crap in the cabinet period of time you
can't touch anything that looks like
that that or that for a period of time
you got to go over there now later on if
you're 180 pounds you know you can have
a cupcake but I'm not suggesting debt at
that point I still don't I still don't
do that right but I mean my point is you
can breathe a little bit be a little bit
but more normal but I'm suggesting Tara
that we push you over to the extreme and
you do weird comfortable things for a
bit to get your get yourself on track
permanently manage your habits yeah
that's good this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
Ty is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Courtney's in Atlanta hi Courtney
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave thanks for taking my call today
sure what's up
okay so I have fallen into the student
loan conundrum I all of my debt is in
student loans I'm 30 years old I have
about 300 000 in student loans
and I am engaged have been for the past
three years because we are scared to get
married we just because of the debt we
are nervous to buy a home we are
currently renting and we want to get
free we are completely new to you and
your show and your plan
um so we just want to go I understand
why you're scared with three hundred
thousand dollars in student loan debt
why
does getting why does that affect
getting married
well I did you tell me you've been
waiting three freaking years
I guess we neither one of us just want
to go to the courthouse and get married
but would you want to be able to pay for
something nicer is what you're saying
right but are you a doctor or a lawyer
um I'm actually a pharmacist what are
you earning 100 and a half
um actually it's more like
122 maybe yes okay does that feel low
it's a little it's a little low but
you're starting you're just you just got
out so
um how long you been out of school
um last three years okay all right
what's his situation I got an undergrad
degree before I actually went into
school in the pharmacy school what does
he make
um he makes UH 60 and then he also gets
uh bonuses um does he have a bunch of
debt too
he actually he actually has no debt
um and
he has very minimal like credit history
though we actually did seek out you know
mortgage pre-approval and we got it but
it was basically yeah you don't you
don't you don't need to buy a house
you're broke so let me tell you let me
tell you a story where we're at let me
tell you a story my husband and I had
280 000 of student loans a little less
than you but if you add our credit cards
in we're you know call it 300. yeah no
credit card for us my point is your
income is a lot better than ours was
back then at least to start and for the
you guys it doesn't matter like Dave
said getting married is not the issue
matter of fact go ahead and get married
work on this thing together and go
through it together and you're just
gonna have to walk through these steps
and commit to the fact that we've got
this debt here for a couple of years
we're living on nothing to get this paid
off luckily you guys got a good shovel
good shovel I'm sorry you've got a good
income and that's it it's just the
student loans right now Courtney you
feel you feel stuck
don't you
I really do and you feel a little bit
ashamed to marry him
and attack and hand him 300K yeah
yeah like you're going this is pretty
serious Dowry here yeah
um
that's all word but yeah
um you know what I'm saying yeah it's um
so it is messing up not getting married
but it's messing up your view of
yourself and your relationships
difficult to budget because you know we
want to have one bank account
um you don't need to have one bank
account until you're married
correct yes let me let me project a
future for you that you haven't seen
let's let's run some numbers for a
second
okay
go get married this weekend
no just just ride with me on my little
trip here okay
just for a second it sounds absurd but
you've been dating for three years
you've been engaged forever
um we'll celebrate in other ways later
uh now
if I calculated correctly you make 122
he makes 60. that's 182. he has no debt
we have now one house to support one set
of rent one set of heat and air one set
of electricity one set of water one set
of things in the refrigerator
you're with me right so your living
costs go down approximately
I also have a car payment what do you
owe on your car
okay I'll put that in the story too okay
now now okay so you make 122 he makes
60. and he has bonuses on top of that
what do you think he'll really make in
the coming 12 months including his
bonuses
um
probably maybe 170 with the I mean maybe
70 with the bonus okay and and I know
this about you you may not but you can
pick up Pharmacy Duty in the ER at the
local hospital on the weekends and you
can make another 25 or 30 if you will
put in a whole bunch more hours than
you're putting in as a temporary measure
okay and so now I'm at 155 and 70. so I
think I'm doing two and a quarter now
anybody with me here
I got three hundred thousand dollars in
student loan debt and I'm going to take
my two and a quarter and I'm gonna live
on 50. that leaves me 175 minus taxes to
put on the 300. you're debt free in two
years
just by picking up extra hours picking
up extra hours living together married
and and spending no money you're not
eating out you're not going on vacation
and you're sure as crud not buying a
house we might be selling your car
right to get a cheaper car but we the
goal here is to get free because
otherwise we're stuck we want to get
free so we can buy a house and live a
great life together and build wealth and
have kids and have kids and be generous
but right now you can't see that because
you've got Mount Everest stuck between
you and hope
right and I just took Mount Everest
apart with a pickaxe in two years
I did that
right but I'm telling you
you're gonna you're you're it's gonna be
a really hard two years
because all the little luxuries you're
accustomed to
none them you get nothing don't you dare
see the inside of a restaurant unless
you're working there
yeah so tuna fish and Dale bread
I agree yes
um so I guess the biggest thing was I
did hear several several of your advices
to other people just being like don't
rely on Public service loan forgiveness
do it yourself it just got you out of
debt in two years why would you even
bring that up right
well because I guess my fiance sees it
as a way out it's not a way out it's a
10-year lie you know what percentage of
the public loans perfect service loans
forgiveness actually get forgiven less
than two percent 98 gets screwed by this
plan
right think about the way you're feeling
right now do you want to feel that for
the next 10 years
waiting on waiting on something that
likely won't happen the reason he wants
you to plug into that he doesn't think
there's another way but you guys make a
lot of money together you sure do and
you can make even more and spend none of
it and throw it all with the student
loans and kill that sucker
150 a year for two years out of two and
a quarter and you're free you're going
to be done in two years it took my
husband and I seven and a half
perspective and we rented the whole time
so and you let that make you and we had
well that was after the fact I know but
for you after seven years was it yeah it
was after the seven years we waited we
rented for here's the stats we rented
for 10 years and waited for 11 years to
have kids wow yep because it was doing
to her what you thought it was doing to
you before this phone call
right now I might be off by a year boy
whoopee and that's fine three years
whoopee I might be off by another year
you might be might do it in a year and a
half because you guys just go bananas
and your husband goes hey game on I'm
working 24 7. we're getting done get
married this weekend and kill this dead
girl do it
I appreciate your advice I feel like
she's not gonna do it
you gotta do it do it please everybody
in America just heard that you are not
thank you for your advice thank you for
calling Courtney
please do it please prove us wrong
oh hey if you don't do it after this you
know whose fault it is Courtney yours
because we have done our job thank you
for calling kiddo oh my goodness
gracious that just happened with 22
million people agreeing this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth
to work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships open phones here
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Jade wash all Ramsay
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Jay just finished
leading a Ramsay personality coordinator
FPU class that's right and that's the
second time you've done that that's
right as a coordinate I mean as a Ramsay
personality you've done it many times
before you joined us here went through
it several times before you joined us
here yes and uh
I think it's a good idea occasionally to
stop and say okay if you're gonna go
through a nine week class on how to
handle money the class that more people
have gone through than any other
Financial class right over 10 million
people have been through it no one's
even a close second
so it is it is the one it's the go it's
number one right so there we go and um
but what hap why do so many people go
through it what happens while you're in
there and you just LED this class so
give me some
insights as a coordinator you watch the
light bulb come on over the top of
people's heads I do I watch people get
introduced to Concepts that they haven't
thought about before or it hasn't been
explained to them why it's important for
it for example everybody knows the word
Insurance oh yeah I'm supposed to have
healthcare insurance I got car insurance
but most people are so confused about
insurance they don't understand how much
coverage they need they're underinsured
they don't realize that or they're over
or they're overwrapping Insurance yeah
and so and a lot of folks when they
first get connected with Ramsay they're
like oh yeah I heard about the baby
steps I'm on baby step two I need all my
money insurance can wait
so I can pay off my debt and that is one
of the biggest things that we find is
people are willing to sacrifice
sometimes in the wrong areas in order to
pay off their debt but it is so
important that you get covered when it
comes to your insurance it's not waiting
until a particular baby step it's as
soon as you find out about it you need
to get it yeah if you don't have car
insurance you need to get car insurance
yeah if you don't have homeowners
insurance renters insurance and you get
it that's right if you don't have health
insurance you're going to get it and put
it in your budget and now we'll go to
work on your goal that's right don't be
that person that Waits so there's that
um of course Dave credit cards are a
huge one but not for the reason that you
might think I mean of course the big uh
argument all the time is the points I
gotta get the points but most people
that come through our class they're
ready uh mentally they said okay the
points don't really matter it's more
about this has become a security blanket
for me and I don't feel confident I
don't think that I can manage my money
without credit cards I've never done it
before I'm ever had to actually say this
is my budget I've got three you know
three four thousand five thousand
dollars and I can only spend that
period they've never had to do it and so
it's actually caused this lack of
confidence in this feeling that oh my
gosh how how what what if I don't live
on list that I make yeah what happens
you mean I can't just go to Target and
get that thing anyway yep
that's what happens yeah so we're seeing
I love when people
cut up their credit card and I can see
their hands shaking I can see that their
shakiness in their voice but then they
come back and they go but Jade I feel so
much better I'm in control now for two
decades American Express told people
don't leave home without it don't leave
home with that and they don't think they
can they don't think they can and I
think that's so sad you work can I just
got to say this you work so hard you're
away from your family your kids eight
nine ten hours a day what have you and
and then you tell yourself all this work
I'm doing all this sacrifice it's not
enough my income's not enough for me I
just read this 500 page
um biographical unbelievable book on
Daniel Boone he left home without it
just saying if he can do it you can do
it I'm saying your grandparents they
left home without it yeah just saying
every other country in the world they
leave home without it credit cards are
relatively new you know yep as you know
so there's that then there's this idea
of and don't get me wrong when I say
this willpower and and discipline and
all that is is very important you got
power through this but some people
forget there's like practical things
that you just got to do like it's not
I keep all my credit cards and I do and
I just have to will Myself White Knuckle
it out I'm like no do some practical get
on a budget set alarms in your phone to
check your budget text your spouse your
credit card cut up the credit card
cancel the account and then remove it
surgery remove it from Amazon take it
off oh put it on put your I got a debit
card on Amazon well you can put that on
there and then if I want to buy
something I can just stay it's like I
have to use my money though yeah isn't
that weird that is that's what scares
people yeah you know and then there's
the folks we talked about this the other
day the the anal paralysis analysis
paralysis is what you called it I call
it something else what are you going
ask hole
yeah you enunciated that carefully I
watched you I had to that means you're
just asking questions man and I get that
you have questions but at some point you
have to act yeah you don't need any
to go do all right and I get that so
those are stuck away from the donut I
mean it's pretty simple you know I mean
that's it back away from the donuts back
away from the overspending yeah cut up
the credit card get you on a budget
there's something you're doing that's
stupid with money and you know it
and there's the little kid part of you
that won't make the grown-up won't let
the grown-up do the grown-up thing
that's right don't be an all
right yeah every shot of every one of us
is the little kid on the cereal I'll
throw in a fit because mom won't Buffalo
okay yeah it exists I I I have felt that
to this day you're lying to yourself
everybody gets in that situation where
you're like
want it so but you can't you gotta just
pull it back together get your life
right all right we know this one Dave
the thousand dollar emergency fund
that's that that is the starter the
starter yep and that's the key it's a
starter it's not enough no kidding
yeah I mean we knew that we're with
inflation inflation's got nothing to do
with not enough it was not enough before
inflation it's not enough after
inflation it's not supposed to be enough
to be and I always tell folks if you
have a thousand dollars you are ahead in
cash that you don't have sitting in your
checking account about to blow right
this is just a separate thousand set
aside for specifically emergencies you
are ahead of the majority of Americans
56 of Americans could not cover a
thousand dollar emergency 36 percent of
Americans have zero
last Insight from Financial Peace
University coordinating the last class
what'd you learn what does it actually
take to be a millionaire can I actually
be a millionaire
and people I love seeing the light bulb
go off when they see the math they see
the math and they go wait a minute I can
do that it doesn't have to do with my I
don't have to be a rocket scientist I
didn't have to be a lawyer I didn't have
to be a anesthesiologist I mean I don't
have to be a famous rock star yeah I can
be a teacher and still be a millionaire
you can be a teacher and be a
millionaire the map it blows your mind
yeah and then you go I'll never be in
debt again because I need that money
that was going to go to the F-150
instead we're going to put it into the
401K we've got all these letters and
numbers mixed up
that's right check it out Financial
Peace University if you want to lead a
class we'd love to have you be a
coordinator like Jade you'll get some of
these insights check out
ramseysolutions.com FPU we can get you
into a class and we can get you leading
a class by the way you can go through
for free if you're the leader that's
pretty cool too this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
we've been doing business at Ramsey for
more than 30 years by now we're a
well-oiled machine but it wasn't always
that way yes we've always had a vision
always had determination and a drive to
help people but what we didn't have was
one central place to access all our
numbers so that we could get further
ahead or quickly see when we needed to
Pivot we were always jumping back and
forth between different systems and
spreadsheets so when netsuite by Oracle
helped us Wrangle our Revenue inventory
expenses and more into one place it was
a game changer and netsuite's number one
Cloud Financial system can help your
business gain the same visibility
because businesses thrive on timely data
and netsuite's real-time analytics can
help your business have immediate access
to your numbers daily so you always know
where you stand and you can move quickly
so go to netsuite.com Ramsey today and
set up a free product tour that's
netsuite.com Ramsey
[Music]
thank you
Jade wash all Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Brittany is with us in
Kansas City hi Brittany welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hi Dave hey what's up
how are you good how you doing
I'm good I'm I'm nervous to be here it's
okay how can we help
good
um I had a quick question so I um my
husband and I have had issues with
buying used cars we're not car people
and most recently we wanted a reliable
SUV and we had it for six months and the
engine locked up and we spent eight
thousand dollars on it and so we're
really looking for advice on
um
what we should do next I it's it's very
tempting I feel like to buy a new car
and because we need something reliable
and we don't want to have to
um worry about uh buying a used car and
issues happening to it so I was
wondering your advice around that what
baby step are you on I'm just curious
um as I'm sorry
I'm new to like Dave Ramsey and
everything so can you explain that sure
I'd be happy to
um are you currently do you currently
have debt to pay off
so we have
a thousand dollars I'm sorry you cut out
what'd you say
um I don't have any credit card debt
good and we have 23 000 in student loans
and what's your household income
household income is
okay so you're new to all things Ramsay
and yet you knew that we said don't buy
a new car brand new car unless unless
you're a millionaire
yes okay
all right that's why I was nervous okay
but you're but but okay so the reason we
don't want you to do that is is if you
tie up uh tell me one more time what
your household income is
25 okay all right and and so what was
the price range of cars that you were
driving that were breaking
um eight thousand dollars eight thousand
dollars is what it costs all right
um now why why I'm making 225 000 a year
I mean given that you aren't doing
Ramsay stuff you just met us why were
you driving such cheap cars
well
um we had a so I have my car which is
already paid off it's a 2018 Malibu I
had already paid that off and then my
husband had a company car for the
longest time for like six years so he
was just driving his company car but how
long have you been making 225 thousand
I'm
only then it jumped to 225 and then
where has all of your money gone to
um
you make a lot of money
have you been paying down
s or something like that or is it just
lifestyle
lifestyle I think and
um we did pay off
in the last six months we paid off all
of our credit cards
and we paid off
um well we paid for that used car but
okay all right so here's the thing
here's the thing you got to sit down
tonight the two of you and go look we
got almost twenty thousand dollars a
month coming in
and we're and yet we're broke
so we need to determine what we're going
to do
with that income sit down look at what
your actual take-home pay is it's
probably more like
um your take-home pay is probably more
like 15.
okay yeah and so you have 15
000 a month you look you have a house
payment
we do have a house how much is your
house payment
my house payment is two thousand okay so
15 000 minus two thousand is thirteen
thousand and I want you to continue that
exercise
minus food minus lights and water
and um I think we're going to find a
disturbing amount of money
like ten thousand dollars a month that
is available to do things with and that
would tell me that you could save up
fairly quickly like before Christmas and
buy a 20 or a twenty five thousand
dollar used car which is an absolutely
fabulous used car and she could also get
out of that student loan debt and pay
off the student loan debt in the process
yeah I mean you've got but but what's
happening is is that uh you guys uh
let the scope creep happen to your
budget your lifestyle scope your life
the scope of your lifestyle creeped
crept up as you um without without
because you weren't paying attention and
that's not evil or bad or lazy even it's
normal but what's not normal is to pay
extreme amounts of attention to every
dollar the two of you together both
doing that and we lay out detailed goals
of exactly what we're going to do with
every free dollar we can squeeze out of
this budget uh and then what the next
thing is we're going to do with every
free dollar and so I hear two really
good big goals on this that I want to do
with the first forty thousand dollars or
fifty thousand dollars that I can get
out of your ten thousand dollar a month
disposable income so that's five months
and I and that's pay off the student
loan and buy a nice car
like that I like that plan a lot
I mean okay you see if you just lay down
and go and what that tells you then is
we're not going to go on vacation
because we want to do these other two
things more what that tells you is we're
not going to spend eight thousand
dollars on Christmas for God's sakes
right and what that tells us is is that
we're not gonna eat out every night for
300 bucks a night that's where it is
right there you know what this tells us
is that uh we're not drinking any more
500 bottles of wine which you
technically can afford but you really
can't because you are broke
yeah even though you have a fabulous
income and that's why you called us and
you're not a you're wonderful people and
you you're very smart people because
dumb people don't make two and a quarter
well if you do but not me
but but in that same breath uh you're 30
of those folks do live paycheck to
paycheck because of what you're talking
about right High income earning broke
people and if you look at yourself that
way then you'll go ah crap something's
got to change here I continue to do the
same thing over and over again expect a
different result that's the definition
of insanity I thought when we started
this conversation you were driving one
thousand dollar cars and spending two
thousand to keep them running and that
maybe you made forty or fifty thousand
dollars a year no she's in the Trap
because the the hard part with with your
situation is you make a good income and
it's so easy to lull yourself to sleep
and go oh we got money coming in we
don't have to look at it we don't have
to think about it we got good incomes
and then before you know it you're more
broke than the person making forty
thousand a year that just keeps eyes and
budgets on their money yeah yeah you and
your husband sit down tonight and say
all right we're done
I'm done worried about a stupid broke
car in a house that makes 225 000. when
you say when you finally say I've had it
yeah that's the phrase that happens
right before you change your life
and just for anybody listening you can't
get a good eight thousand dollar car I
don't I want people to know you can you
can do it yeah but but yeah yeah
absolutely you can that's very possible
I mean she obviously got a bad one but
yeah uh but you know in your case the
cars are not the problem uh the old cars
are not the problem they're the symptom
of you being completely unintentional
and out of control with this fabulous
income that's right and that's not to
pick on you so I appreciate you calling
in here nervous and we're not throwing
you under the bus we've both done
exactly the same thing bad dumb stuff
with money too so we know it when we see
it I know what stupid looks like I used
to look at it in the mirror so uh you
know I'm not gonna not gonna ask you to
but but here's the thing though I just
want to give you the power that comes to
you when you start telling every dollar
what to do and pointing every free
dollar at things that really matter more
to you than going out to eat this week
Now Dave what about that 500 bottle of
wine
if you make two and a quarter you can
drink a 500 bottle of wine if you're not
broke if you're not broke
all right I might have to keep guarantee
you they have
I'll guarantee you should I need to make
some life lifestyle changes in here then
500 on a bottle of wine you had to
I said when you made a two and a quarter
it's an option if you're not broke and
so you know you got to get to where
you're not broke first so let's have you
know maybe we should base this on net
worth and not income okay
you don't want to be drinking your net
worth all right so let's just keep that
in mind that's right wow
[Music]
uh well and here's the thing Jay for
just for you we'll serve it with
hamburger let's go let's go this is the
Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
Hollow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling hallow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hallow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Kathleen
is with us in Austin Texas hey Kathleen
how are you
[Music]
good afternoon what's up
so
um so I feel pretty alone in my
situation
um
we possibly need to sell our home to
move closer in my husband's job okay
um but we're both 27 so I don't want to
do anything stupid okay so
um we bought this house
for 387 000 in February of 2022.
since then our property has decreased in
value not increased
who said
the market no Realtors the comps all
that yeah it's crazy did you massively
overpay and getting some weird bidding
war when he bought it um I did not get
in a bit anymore we got it from a new
construction it's what they were asking
um we fell into the like
um will offer you like so much down for
closing
stuff so I mean I think it was 380 after
they paid closing costs
um
but our home has lost
a lot of money over the past year
literally a year
um Kathleen something's wrong
because Austin Texas has not lost real
estate value
okay so we're in the suburb of Austin in
Kyle Texas okay how far out of Austin is
that
Kyle
is so we're 30 minutes from downtown off
and off there's something wrong in this
I don't understand because we get we get
real estate reports from all over the
nation we work with realtors in every
real estate agents in every major city
and Austin Texas is not losing money
and 30 minutes outside of Austin is
Austin from an economic standpoint and
so I don't understand the story
um you overpaid or you've gotten bad
information about what it's actually
worth today
this potential that we overpaid
um
totally we were in the so this is the
only home we could afford in Austin
Texas because we moved from Memphis
Tennessee where like everything was
affordable but crime was getting really
bad in our area so we moved as soon as
we could and when we moved to Austin
Texas
um
we just jumped on the house that we
could afford and Kyle Texas was where it
was and
all the homes around us right now are
selling for 315 to 340.
and it's a lot of lost equity and we put
down 87 000 when we purchased the home
for a down payment
so okay anyways with all that to be said
um okay I think I I think I'm hearing
that you rushed in impulsively about
something in a panic and dramatically
overpaid I think that's what I'm hearing
yeah I believe that's correct based off
of the cops right now I believe
nationally the statistics are that
Austin Texas has gone up in the last 12
months
in values not down and and if you're 30
minutes outside of Austin you're in
Austin okay that's a suburb of Austin so
you're just that that area is not
economically blighted
it's just not and so um that's what I
want to I want to put that out there for
everybody in America because I don't
want somebody going oh that lady you
know now this lady overpaid because she
impulsively bought something because she
was running from Memphis like her hair
was on fire and so uh that that's what's
going on now back to your question
though now that I understand how we got
here so you likely are going to lose
money but you put down a large down
payment so you won't write a check to
sell it right
correct we will have about 30 000 still
left if we sell the house at 335 which
is and so your husband's driving an hour
he doesn't want to drive anymore do we
sell it and move close to his work
that's what you're considering right
right so he drives about two and a half
hours a day and we have two toddlers
that just like ask for Dada all the time
yeah and when you bought the house did
you know where he was going to be
working
um he did re he moved jobs he worked
with whenever he moved here it was a
relocation with his previous job in
Memphis and he didn't like the work so
he took a job
way far away from his family
I do I do too
I'm not doing it
um exactly yeah so but but you my point
is you got signed up for all these trips
you're taking
yes so I agree with your initial
statement of we don't need to do that
anymore
so is he going to stay at this job
I mean he likes it so like what does he
make
he makes 98 000 and I'm just a
State yeah and not just don't say Jess
don't ever say just
um and and uh what what does he actually
do
mechanical
[Music]
a company
doing private stuff yeah okay well I
guess the the bottom line is number one
we need to have a pattern uh going
forward of different decision making
and uh because these are big decisions
quitting your job and deciding to
commute an extra hour is a big decision
rushing and buying a home in a panic is
a big decision okay and so we've got
both of these things are not we're not
we're not well thought out so if we I'm
with you I'm concerned that we're
thinking this one out without thinking
about the other intended unintended
consequences so in other words if you
guys do this and you take this hit and
you move close to his work he's staying
at that job
right no more
bitten around
yeah
and we're going to think through stuff
well here's the yeah your move okay
they're going to be renting because they
don't have any money to put down on
another home we got 30.
but that's not much yeah I don't you may
be renting yeah I'm okay if you keep it
and sit there and commute until the
until you see some value recut not some
value until you see values go up the
values aren't going to recover because
they were never there in the first place
you overpaid but uh so that's the thing
um
yeah I would love to know her neighbors
what they paid well she said that
neighborhood everybody in the
neighborhoods are 3 15. well she said
that's what the houses are worth I want
to know what did they pay getting in you
know what I mean I want to know if
everybody's screwed or you know
that's very very strange very strange
okay
um
would I take a 40 000 hit
that would be cool to get rid of a
commute
I'd be 50 50 and I'm 50 50 right now I
hate the commute and I hate the fifty
thousand dollar forty thousand dollar
hit I'm not sure which one I hate more I
hate it because this is their second
house they had they obviously rolled 87
000 from their first sale into this one
and then they'd be walking out with
little to nothing
I I just hate that
um starting from scratch after two home
purchases feels
but that being said it's going to take
them a little while living there to
recoup it
yeah it's tough
I don't know I mean I guess the third
option is he gets a job closer to home
yeah that's true which it doesn't sound
it sounds fairly rural no it's not only
30 minutes outside of Austin there's
nothing 30 minutes I said Austin this
rule okay maybe I just big city okay
then there's like 30 minutes outside of
Nashville okay you're not you're not
you're not gonna be there's nothing rule
30 minutes a little bit but not much
yeah you know so yeah
I'm not sure hun I'm on the I'm on the
needle for you on the bubble for you I
don't know which one to tell you to do
um uh I do know you guys need to think
through what you're creating each time
you make these moves because both of
these moves you didn't think through
yeah the job changer didn't think
through and the purchase of this home
you didn't think through they were both
done uh a bit impulsively uh uh um
and so if you're gonna make this move
don't do it impulsively really think
through what what we're giving up and
what we're trading out and why we're
doing it and what that means to his
stability of it you got to know he's
stable at the new place and he's going
to stay there at the new place or you
don't do this for sure this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today Brian is
in New York City hey Brian welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hello thanks for taking the question
um so I'm 33 I'm Single Living in New
York uh I have about a half million
dollar income with about half a million
in cash and uh Investments good so a
couple with that thank you with that
context I wanted to get your perspective
on you know how should I think about
where I should be financially over the
next five to 15 20 years or so and then
as part of that Journey how should I
think about buying a house in or or a
condo in a very expensive area and then
how much I should allocate towards
having fun their hobbies and
specifically
buying vintage cars that's kind of an
expensive hobby it's a good hobby
ah got a few of them myself
um
what do you think what's your plan
because you've done a really good job
you know I haven't really given it a
significant amount of thought in terms
of prepping for when I want to retire
it's really just been headed down and
saving as much as I can I would have
liked to have
saved more but uh you know it's uh
focusing on the future I really haven't
given it much thought I just know that I
should probably buy a house those that
store the cars but then that comes with
cost and it's like how should I balance
that between
trying to retire early if that's an
option well it's all about
um your ratios and how you're spending
your money so you said you make an
income of about a half a million dollars
is that right
yeah so when you go to look for real
estate you want to make sure that what
you're looking for is not cutting as a
percentage too far into your you know
take-home pay which you've got a lot to
work with but you're also in a very
expensive area
and so when the time comes to purchase
real estate the way that we would do it
obviously in your situation obviously
you want to pay save up pay a large down
payment but whatever you choose you
don't want it to be more than 25 of your
take-home pay so that you're leaving
more of that income to do the things
that you want to do in your case build
more wealth right
so a good a good way of thinking about
this is that there are three things you
can do with money and you always need to
be doing all three
you need to be generous
you need to be saving investing and you
need to be enjoying it
Okay so we've covered saving and
investing uh buying a house as an
investment uh Investing For for wealth
building is is there you know lifestyle
would be vintage cars enjoying right
um so you need you need in generosity in
your mix and you can decide that but
when I work with and I've worked with uh
like famous people or even non-famous
people that make a bazillion dollars
okay like I sat with a guy not long ago
made 15 million last year so how do you
decide what to do with that
um all I want to do is put a percentage
of my income towards each thing
and the total is a hundred okay so what
percentage of my income after taxes is
going to go to generosity what
going to go into Investments
and what percentage of my income is
going to go to Lifestyle and Sharon and
I do that now Brian so like I got a
really nice check-in the other day from
the publisher on Total Money Makeover
it's a big old check and
um I've already know where that's going
a certain percentage number one 50 is
gone before I start because you know
government's going to take 40. and I'm
going to give a tenth because I'm an
Evangelical Christian my my Baseline
generosity is a tithe in my case and so
that's 50 okay 40 for taxes and 10 for
that that leaves me the other 50 percent
and we have that broken down a certain
percentage for enjoyment and a certain
percentage for
um
further investing and a certain
percentage for further generosity out of
that last 50 you follow me and so that
way when I go buy a vintage car which
like I said I've got a couple uh it
comes out of that percentage and it's
really not a very big percentage but I'm
make good money so that little bitty
percentage is still a lot of money I can
still go on really nice trips I can
still do this thing and it's it's a very
small percentage of My overall income
and of My overall net worth but it's
still a really really good life and
that's where you are Brian you make a
lot of money and so if you said I'm
going to give away 10 a year that'd be
fifty thousand if you said I'm going to
invest 40 percent a year and you know
I'm going to enjoy five per or ten
percent a year above my household budget
um you know I'm gonna take my household
budget out of the half million income
set us at 100 to operate because now I
got 400 and I'm going to break that down
and if you put you know 10 percent
towards
and 20 towards enjoyment it isn't long
before you start buying some cars with
that you so you can you but you get to
decide those percentages I don't care
what they are but here the whole point
is to be intentional and touch all three
bases and the percentages
it helps keep your head on straight
because you're not going
forty thousand dollars that's a lot of
money you're looking at it you're like
oh it's ten percent or it's 20 yeah it's
well the ratios tell you you're not
being
irresponsible with your enjoyment or
with your generosity the ratios tell you
that
um hey I'm doing a good amount towards
investing but I'm not only investing I'm
not uh uh Simon Legree and I'm just
piling up coins that's right you know
I'm I'm some people don't know what that
is I'm not greedy I'm not Scrooge McDuck
there you go I'm not just piling up
coins and so um
because you don't want to only invest
and uh so it's a good uh psychological
emotional maturity uh spiritual maturity
exercise to have money assigned to the
different areas of your life and then
you can enjoy the generosity and you
know his his percentages are gonna go
they are not going to go the same
the percentage if you live lived in they
won't for the house the lifestyle it
could I mean a vintage cars cost the
same in New York Miami so my point is
his cost of living percentage may not go
he may make that a larger percentage
because it doesn't go as far yeah and
that's okay that's okay yeah that's okay
yeah I mean yeah you would need to you
would need more to operate for
operational budget in New York City than
you would in Abilene for sure yeah no
question about that
um and that's cool though and you had
that show very well done Brian but I
think that that the way we work with for
instance celebrities are athletes or
whatever and they're making
you know uh 5x or 10x what you're making
in some case or more uh is that exact
process and it will work for your half
million dollar income as well that idea
will uh and the whole thing is to be
able to do each one without
uh dread without trepidation without
shame uh because because we know we have
done a reasonable amount towards each
and that walks you through that so
that's very very good he's just getting
started 33 with a half million dollar
income
way to go man obviously you're extremely
bright dude that's that's very very cool
and um
you know in our culture today you guys
uh it's a good thing to run into people
like Brian and be sure that you um are
celebrating them
you're happy for them uh because we have
a tremendous problem with uh the science
uh uh of Envy it must be nice it's Envy
or uh jealousy jealousy is I want what
you have Envy is I don't even want you
to have what you have
yeah that's true
the words I hate the most oh he's makes
half a million must be nice yeah like
ask him how he did it how about what and
how about awesome way to go Brian yeah
we didn't even ask him how he did it
because all we want to do is celebrate
it that's right and we know he's smart
we know he's happy for you yeah I always
we assume he's not selling cocaine you
know we just assume that right so we
don't get a lot of calls from the
cocaine people here so we're pretty sure
of that so I mean we're sure he's doing
good somewhere in the society it's some
level to make that kind of money and so
be happy for me celebrate success again
America that's right celebrate that hard
work pays off celebrate that being smart
pays off celebrate the common sense and
discipline pays off don't envy it
and don't teach your children to be
Marxist teach them to be capitalists
that's right that's what I'm talking
about
freaking socialism it's unbelievable it
is unbelievable based and envy and
jealousy and so celebrate success
celebrate the the good that a guy like
Brian is doing should be giving us hope
absolutely
that puts us out of the Ramsay show in
the books
[Music]
thank you
hey what's up guys it's Jade if you love
the show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramsaysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramseysolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth
do work that they love and create actual
amazing relationships Jade wash all
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five if you are
listening to this show and loving this
show help us out spread the word for us
yeah that's right hit the share button
or tell people about it or click a link
and share the link or whatever it is
however you're youtubing or podcasting
or tbning or talk radioing let people
know where you're listening and tell
them to join us we would love to have
them also hit subscribe or follow or
whatever is appropriate and every time
you do those kinds of things it helps
the show be uh automatically pushed
forward on the internet to and on your
particular format that you're doing it
to other potential viewers listeners and
we appreciate that because it a bunch of
folks have joined since the first of the
year our ratings and rankings and all
measures are way up and it means you
guys are sharing it and leave a five
star review too thank you very much all
right zoo is with us in San Francisco hi
Zoo how are you
hey Mr fancy how are you great how can
we help
so great to hear I am calling because
I'm so tired of living the life that I'm
living and I need your help
so
um the reason that I'm calling is
because I need to know or we need to
know my husband and I need to know how
to get my husband on board with the plan
and care about our home finances hmm
um we got married back in April of 2020
and my husband said that he had income
to bring to a marriage he come to find
out he had no money at all to come into
the marriage not even for the honeymoon
so he wasn't working our marriage
um or no savings
but no savings okay
nothing savings he made a mistake or he
lied to you
how much
oh I have enough money for like six
months of expenses
he was moving from Michigan to
California at that time and it was a
flattering way
it's flat out completely yes what else
has he lied about
ending
um he has borrowed so much money from
family members and
so we have our finances together now but
it's just not it doesn't seem to be
working well because you don't trust him
I I trust him yes I mean why give like
why do I trust him because he's my
husband no that no
you don't trust I mean I have a dog I
had a dog one time that would bite you
and he's my dog but he would bite you
I didn't trust him yeah even though he's
my dog
this dog bites oh my gosh
so what are y'all doing what are y'all
doing to build your relationship after
it started on lies
so we go to church and we've been
getting counseling at church and every
time we need like we need quarterly and
she's like yeah I'm going to change but
they it had he has not changed one bit
it's only getting worse and we've been
trying to start your plan since the
beginning of the year you don't need to
start our plan hey what's he spending
money on uh you said that he's he's
spending money he's not telling you
about it what's he spending that money
on she's spending money on GoPros
Electronics camera
he's 27.
so she married a child yeah
because boy that's what kids do they do
things they know they're not supposed to
do and then when Mommy says what'd you
do they lie about it
and then Mommy says okay you're in
timeout and they they say okay I thought
about what I did and then they go back
and do the same thing again
that's exactly we got it to the point
that's exactly what's going on I'm sorry
that's frustrating uh I can't get him on
our plan our plan is for grown-ups
so he's got you guys have to continue
and engage in in-depth counseling for
your marriage you guys you're in a mess
honey I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry because this this guy does
not want to engage anything that
requires self-discipline self-control
um maturity the ability to delay
pleasure for a greater good
um he is about him he's not about you
he's not about your marriage he's not
about your future he's about him I can't
help someone in that situation I'd love
to but the best way I can help him is to
be mean enough to him that he goes and
does something good for himself
and it starts starts to grow up because
you know a man
not a 27 year old male but a man
does not put his personal desires and
purchases in a lie ahead of the good of
the family and the good of his wife
and that's what you're facing right yeah
I'm so sorry me too I'm so sorry yeah I
wish I wish I could I mean if I thought
I could take you guys if you guys were
both ready to go but you the work you
all need to the time you need to be
spending is not on Financial Peace
University it you need to be spending
time in the marriage counselor's office
and and you know and if he won't go your
marriage counselor needs to help you
decide in your church setting what is at
what point is this marriage done
because I can promise you it's done if
he doesn't change I don't know whether
it's a decade
or whether it's 10 days
or 10 months but it's uh but but I've
worked doing what I'm doing and I and I
know that I don't believe in divorce I
don't I'm not telling you to get a
divorce I'm not doing any of that but
I've worked with couples long enough to
know the lady in your situation will
hold her breath for some period of time
and when the when the volcano finally
goes off there's no putting the lava
back in I know that's right it's over
the switch is flipped and we be done and
no amount of spiritual shaming or
anything else will undo that I know
that's right so uh please please please
the two of you for the good of your
future for the good of each other spend
time on uh getting in a good solid
winning relationship where you're
serving each other not being selfish
being selfless and that's you know the
an immature and all of these things are
so so hard so hard wow I'm so sorry
so guys um disclosing a hundred percent
in truth of who you are about money and
exactly what the dollars and cents are
how much is in savings how much is in
retirement how much you make
um really early in the dating process is
uh is a valid thing because Jesus said
your treasure is where your heart is so
how you handle money and where the money
goes speaks about who you are as a
person it's a description of your value
it is and your values rather and so uh
young ladies demand that of these young
males to see if they're men young men
demand that of these young females to
see if they're grown women instead of
little princesses is you don't you don't
want to you don't want this guys it's
not fun it's not fun
oh so sad this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
y'all there's a lot you can't control
when it comes to health care but there
is something you should check out that
can help Christian Healthcare Ministries
chm is not Insurance it is
budget-friendly biblically based Health
cost sharing that means a community of
members helping share the burden of each
other's health care costs they help
people just like you in all 50 states so
see if chm could be right for your
family learn more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
thank you for joining us America Jade
warshaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today we appreciate you hanging out with
us uh paying off debt is smart saving
and investing is smart but there's
another key to winning with money and
that is the defense side that's called
protecting your finances that's called
Insurance there are 10 kinds of
insurance coverage you might need
and no more
that's all you don't need all the
skimmick stuff and all these I need I
need insurance for my Chihuahua's
toenails oh my God you people it's
unbelievable what you get insurance on
no there's ten kinds of basic insurance
you need you need to self-insure with
your emergency fund through everything
else we're going to help you do that
with a coverage checkup
to show you which types you need to add
drop or adjust we'll even rank your
coverage list by importance email it to
you and connect you with a Ramsey
trusted insurance provider that will
shop a bazillion different companies and
get you the best price on each type that
you do need go to ramsesolutions.com
checkup
ramsesolutions.com slash checkup Becky
is in Charlotte North Carolina hi Becky
welcome to the Ramsay show
sure what's up
so I am working on the baby steps I have
completed baby step one and I'm working
off all of my debt um but I had a
question I feel like my car is quite
possibly on its last leg so I am
wondering if I should increase my
emergency fund to help to potentially
cover any major repairs or possibly
needing to buy kind of another reliable
A to B outright without a new note I
would start putting money aside like a
sinking fund if I knew that a car repair
was up and coming so why do you think
that
um so a whole slew of reasons um it's a
2009 Camry which obviously Camrys are
very reliable but we are inching close
to 250 000 miles I know for a fact based
on previous repair experiences that I've
had that there's an oil valve gasket
leak
um the idle is starting to get really
really rough the exhaust doesn't sound
good
um so I mean a whole slew of things that
are indicating that it may potentially
go and maybe within the next six months
to a year and I want to make sure that
I'm prepared to take care of anything I
need to take care of also not neglecting
the fact that I'm trying to work off
that
what's your household income
[Music]
I didn't ask a person I said you are you
the only income
okay then that's not a household I mean
you're if you're not married it's you
okay so you you have an income of what
uh 57.5 with potential for bonuses and
your debt is right
um I've got about fifty thousand dollars
left on what
uh 40 is student loans and 10 is a
personal loan that I have mapped out
that if I pay as much as I possibly can
I could get rid of it by December good
no very good yeah you're doing a good
job
thank you you're driving a two thousand
dollar one thousand dollar car yeah yeah
and you got a one thousand dollar
emergency fund
um there's 1500 in it now because I did
kind of start building a sinking fund
but I wanted to make sure that that was
the right direction to take this
okay I know I do not violate the baby
steps okay what I do
what we do from time to time is say look
at a situation and say there's an
emergency
there's an emergency you have to stop
everything
and cover the emergency
all right now obviously you don't make
enough money to buy a car on one month's
income if you uh did this so no I'm not
gonna do a sinking fund for a car I
disagree with Jade while I'm working on
the baby steps uh if we're going to
declare the car
dying
gasping it has a death rattle which is
what you're declaring it then we might
say we're going to stop everything so
you're going storm mode and say yeah and
say okay for two months we're going to
pile up and let's go get let's sell this
1500 car put two thousand with it and
get a three times better car for twice
the money right
okay and then restart because I think
you could get two thousand dollars
together in about a month couldn't you
yeah absolutely yeah if you took the two
thousand dollars plus your car you get a
3 500 car give or take
and that'd be a lot better car than the
one you got probably
oh yeah I can tell you actually you have
a clue about this which is very good
that puts you ahead of the curve so yeah
I I might do that and then when I say
that
I'm making you stop your debt snowball
for a minute you kind of went gulp
because you're on it
and stopping that dead snowball doesn't
sound fun
and that makes you analyze how serious
you are about whether these you think
this car is really going to break or not
oh
easy person yeah you're running a flow
chart I heard it
yeah if this then that yeah and uh
that's good it's good it's a good
decision-making Paradigm that you're
using your decision making skills are
excellent so I'm okay with a full stop
and my upgrading car I'm okay driving
the car for 60 more days and let's see
how we're doing staying dead on the debt
snowball
no additional savings
and if it's scaring you even more full
stop
because I think if you'll give yourself
30 days worth of notice before car dies
you can have your other car
we obviously don't want it to die in the
middle of it okay and then the other
question that comes to mind is does it
just simply need a tune-up
yeah that's that's also on my radar um
of the things that have been evaluated
thus far I would probably be looking at
between five and six hundred dollars
that's a budget item a car repair is a
budget item exactly and so that would
you know uh I might tune it up now I'm
not going to spend
three thousand dollars on a fifteen
hundred dollar car
but if I can spend two or three hundred
bucks and get rid of the the uh the
coughing and the sputtering and you know
whether it's cleaning the fuel injectors
or whatever they're doing and get the
thing running right again and that buys
me enough time to finish off the student
loan debt boy that would have been a
good move right but if I do that and I
find out hey I really got to get rid of
this thing it's going to die then we
push full stop and go get a let's go get
you a car and then push full go I don't
I don't really want to play Both Sides
at the same time you follow me yeah not
at the same time I've got to be able to
come up with a plan of attack based on
either stop and get the car or wait a
little bit and then stop and get the car
and in the meantime tune it up see if it
works that's probably my plan I'm
probably going to take a run at the
tune-up and then revisit this decision
90 days from now
yeah if I'm still really scared then I'm
gonna push full stop go get a car and
then push full start and get out of debt
because you're not going and buying a 25
000 car I mean you're being you're being
everything you're giving us is very wise
your level of Common Sense is excellent
you really are on it girl I'm proud of
you
well thank you so much so I think she's
winning don't you look she's living with
roommates she's doing what she got to do
to get out of this debt yeah I'm driving
a junkie Buck car I mean making a
thousand dollar car yes
yeah I mean it's it's um like she said
cameras are good cars but they die too
yeah that's true 250 000 is a
wow okay so cars are this
like she she mentioned a to B see
somebody has taught her so well yeah
she's smart that was not our phrase yeah
but that's exact this is a car is an A
to B thing everything above the
transportation that gets you from A to B
is a luxury
luxuries are not evil
I drive a really nice expensive car it's
a luxury though it's
ridiculous and uh
and but the actual Transportation
function is a to B and every one of us
can do that for five grand mm-hmm
very reliable
Trent and air conditioner works yeah and
get from A to B everything above that is
luxury
and that's okay but I need a new car
when you're driving a fifteen thousand
dollar car is not a factual statement
I want a nicer car
is an okay statement and it's factual
but don't talk yourself into needs when
they're not needs call them what they
are their wants her case we're dealing
with need that's this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their one
action guarantee and shipping is always
free see whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thank
you for joining us America Nate is with
us in Pennsylvania hi Nate welcome to
the Ramsay show
hey Dave how's it going better than I
deserve what's up
hey I have a question for you uh kind of
sounds like a little bit of a dilemma
that I've been feeling uneasy about
um let me start off I'm in baby step
number one uh just working to save a
thousand dollars right now
um I have thirty two thousand dollars in
debt uh I have a fifteen thousand dollar
um car loan that I'm actually trying to
sell this week it's worth 19 private
value
um so hopefully that will work out for
me there my other dilemma here is that
um
I had agreed to this vacation with my
girlfriend that her parents got for us
to go to Key West and she's like all you
got to do is pay 600 my mom paid for got
us the tickets already and I'm just
chilling really uneasy about that being
that I'm on beans and rice right now and
I don't want to do anything like that I
also don't want to disappoint anybody or
hurt anyone's feelings I'm sorry tell me
the trip again
a trip
but not fully yes
exactly so they they announced to you
that they're giving you the gift of a
trip but you have to pay for it
correct for the flight oh for the flight
but when they announced that they were
giving you the trip did they announce
that you were going to pay for the
flight
yes this was something that I was aware
of but now moving forward and seeing
that I've just started the baby steps
I'm like this is something I'm not
comfortable with doing now and I feel
like I'm kind of locked into it have the
tickets been purchased what do I do
have the tickets been purchased
yes
they purchased them and they're asking
you to re reimburse them
yes then they purchased them after you
agreed to this
yes I did agree to it and then they went
and bought the tickets
yes and now I'm feeling uneasy about it
you bought a ticket
stupid tax I'm sorry say that again I
said that's tough you've told me to go
buy your ticket and they went and bought
you a ticket you owe for the ticket
you're going yep yeah sorry if you
regret it but yeah you you you promised
these people you're going to pay them
let me tell you what yeah you're dating
my daughter and you tell me you're going
to do something and then you don't do it
that's a problem I don't want to mess
with that problem Dave yeah
you I mean you gave your word now if
they sprung this on you and then then
expected you to pay for the ticket well
that's them violating a boundary but
they made a proposal they said hey we'll
go on a trip we'll pay for everything
but the airline you pick up your own
Airline and you said I'm in yeah but now
you have you have buyer's remorse is
really what it
trickles down to yeah that's not where
I'm at I guess yeah I'm sorry Nate you
bought an airline ticket
you need to pay for it you need to go on
the trip and smile
are you going to do that
yeah you can't you can't be a butthead
on the trip because you have to pay are
you going to go on the trip and pay them
for the ticket
oh I'm gonna have to yeah yeah okay good
all right and be nice
because this is what you signed up for
the trip
they did not do something to you you did
something to you
yeah that's true okay all right now go
ahead I'm sorry your second question is
what
just real quick now being that I'm in
baby step number one and uh getting
ready to sell my car I have 32 000 in
debt and I'm uh looking to get that down
to iOS 15 on it so I'm looking to get
that down to about looks about 17 000
wrestling what are I'm bringing in 45 a
year what is what is going to be my
timeline for getting out of debt how
many hours a week are you working now
40 a week okay oh you're gonna double
that
get your income up another 30 and you'll
be out of debt in a year the faster the
the more income the more you have thrown
at this debt the faster it's going to
eliminate yeah I mean you're selling
your car for this goal now go give some
of your hours give some blood to this
goal right I know there's some Blood
Sweat and Tears And in regards to
getting an A to B carve can I go ahead
and get that or yeah
pay cash for it yeah when you sell this
other car you said you gotta get
Transportation right
I should have three or four thousand
dollars I do drive a company vehicle you
have to have you can you use the company
vehicle to go to the grocery store
legally
yes
so why do you have to have another car
I guess it's not completely necessary
not today
no it's it's I mean you you have
transportation you're allowed the
company allows you to drive to church in
the company car or to go to the grocery
store in the company car personal use
reasonable personal use
yep then then drive the company car
mm-hmm
and later on when you get out of debt if
you want to pile up a money and get you
a five thousand ten thousand dollar car
to sit in the driveway that's fine but
this car sits in the driveway this is a
very expensive luxury sure is yeah I'm
already throwing it away yeah yeah I I'm
hey all right listen let me tell you the
way my mind works in this okay I don't
want to work 80 hour weeks any longer
than I have to so if I'm you I'm trading
that three or four thousand dollars to
shorten the number of weeks I have to
work my tail end off to get the debt
paid off
okay that's what I'm doing that's how my
mind went when we said do we buy another
car or do we throw this three or four at
it so uh hey I I sense that you're in a
really key moment in your life that a
whole bunch of things are changing for
you at once in a good way there's a lot
of growing up going on there's a lot of
stepping into responsibility going on uh
you're asking ethical questions lots of
good things happening with you right now
I want you to continue to lean into all
of this and don't pull back from it
because if you may feel the fire a
little bit on some of this time this
time of transformation for you you may
feel some heat at some point lean into
the heat don't back up from it because I
think God's got some really cool things
for you coming Nate I love that don't
you I believe it there's a whole bunch
of different points in that story yeah
you can tell that his priorities his
priorities are shifting he's starting to
put a lot more thought into the
decisions that he's making I think he's
about to buy her a ring hey hey just
make sure she's on board with a plan I'm
but I'm thinking I think I think and I
think that made him get real serious
about ethics not only with her parents
but everybody get real serious about
getting this mess cleaned up that'll do
with the house on the market
I'm I'm so serious I'm going to call
Dave and Jade and let them beat me up if
I have to let's go get it done you know
yeah and that that was he's in a cool
place I like this guy good for him yeah
true I do I do our question of the day
comes from neighborly your hub for Home
Services don't wait until the AC or
something else goes out neighborly helps
you find local providers like Air
Service Mr Appliance and dryer vent
wizard go to neighborly.com today all
right today's question comes from Katie
in Atlanta what changes do you think
you'd make to the baby steps for those
without kids I have no errors to leave
anything to and no reason to save for
college I need enough pay for senior
care since I won't have children to help
me but if I die with millions in the
bank it seems like a fail so really good
question and a unique question when I
think about the baby steps I mean
obviously if you don't have kids you can
just simply omit baby step five I mean
that's easy I do think that everybody
needs a will because you should
determine what happens with your things
and with your stuff you don't want the
government to decide that you know state
or you know local officials to decide
that and then I'm looking at a pile of
wealth at the end of your life is not a
waste it's not out of waste it was it
gave you insurance that you had equality
exit yeah that you had a quality people
around you and there's something you're
completely leaving out Katie and that's
the joy of generosity I was just gonna
say I was getting just getting to that
you don't have to the whole point of
gathering is to be able to give it's the
live and give like no one else it's not
just the live
it's just it's not just the living part
so give like no one else uh and this
next part of the question I feel like
answers itself I need enough to pay for
senior care since I won't have children
well we do recommend getting long-term
care at the right point but if you've
got five million dollars yeah she may
not just start writing checks to nursing
homes and then and and you know you say
the last chapter of my life I'm gonna
spend my way around finding somebody
that's hungry and feeding them I'm gonna
spend some time making sure a kid has
some shoes I'm going to spend some and
you can you can go through some you
would have the that'd be the best years
of your life well and she might end up
with a dude she might end up with a
husband we don't know might change the
whole thing you know we don't know
Katie's story yeah we don't know how old
she is but
yeah keep just walk the baby steps as
they are oatmeal omit what you don't
need and you do need a will there you go
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
our scripture of the day First
Corinthians 15 58 therefore my dear
brothers and sisters stand firm let
nothing move you always give yourselves
fully to the work of the Lord because
you know that your labor in the Lord is
not in vain
Ken Blanchard said there's a difference
between interest and commitment when
you're interested in doing something you
do it only when it's convenient when
you're committed to do something you
accept no excuses only results
yeah I'll just step up there big can
that's it I like it Shanna is with us in
Fort Worth Texas hi Shanna how are you
Dave and Jade my question is uh how to
help my kids with their finances they're
pretty good about listening to us but I
need your advice on helping to advise
them on how to be wise with their money
and maybe the best place to put it how
old are they I have my daughter is a
June going to be a junior in high school
and my son is going to be a junior in
college
and um my daughter paid for half of her
car and we paid the other half so it's
paid off and then she has twenty
thousand dollars in her checking account
okay both of them are both of them are
dependent on you
um pretty much my um pretty much the
junior in college is too and say yeah
you're paying for it
yes yeah and it's called dependent yeah
yeah
um
also has a paid for vehicle and 27 000
in his checking but he also has uh 250
000 in a custodial account that he
didn't use for college because he has a
full ride academic scholarship wonderful
wonderful
and my daughter will have that too but
she'll go ahead and tell you that she's
not uh she's probably not going to get a
full academic scholarship so she's just
trying to think of what to do too yes
okay all right so she's got a 250 000
custodial account as well
all right good very good mom and dad
well done all right
um
well there's two sets of things going on
number one anything that you do while
you're on my payroll
I get to decide
if I have to if I have to
I'm going to start with persuasion and
teaching wisdom
and hopefully just talk you into doing
the right thing but you're not going to
do stupid while I fund the other parts
of your life
because I am not confused about who the
parent is
okay so as long as you're as long as I'm
supporting you
I hold the ultimate control the trump
card I don't want to use it with kids
that old I want then I want to lead them
with persuasion and facts into good
decisions so that's with current
decisions for instance uh your these
kids sound like they're very
level-headed it sounds like you guys
have done a great job with them but I'll
just give you a weird one let's say your
son who's in college
uh decides he's going to go buy a 70 000
uh car
well no he's not
no he's not right okay we're not going
to do that if you do that then you're
off the payroll and you're 100 on your
own
and we will love you but we you will be
our stupid child that we love
but we're not funny we're not funding
squat
and you know we're not gonna you know or
he decides he's going to go
join a cult or whatever you know what
I'm saying
I'm not I am not without controlling my
ability to continue to put money in this
situation I will stop putting money in
this situation the junior in high school
at home I'm in complete control
they don't have rights except to not be
abused
and Shannon so much of what they learn
going forward as they become adults
about money is gonna be from you no you
already have yeah you do a great job
they're looking at how you spend money
do you spend more than you can afford
how do you guys speak about money in the
household how do you guys decide if a
purchase is wise or not they're take
they're soaking all that up like sponges
once I've laid that hardcore Foundation
under my decision-making paradigm I'll
never use it I hope
that I was talking about so I'm not
suggesting you come in with an iron fist
or something I'm not at all and then I'm
going to start the persuasion on the
day-to-day the future of what the kid
does with 250 000 when he is has
graduated from college with no debt and
has by then forty or fifty thousand
dollars in his savings account he's
obviously a great kid but if he decides
to do something stupid and he's 24 years
old you have zero power
over future decisions your only Power
you have there is persuasion yeah I feel
like that's the hardest part is
stage of parenting when your kids are
when you have quote grown kids which is
an oxymoron but yeah but yeah yeah
you're when the when the children you
have sire to become adults yes and so
yeah it's and then they get to do what
they want to do even if you don't agree
with it now I'm blessed in the hours our
our three have never done anything
bizarre outside of our belief system uh
that I had to really bite my tongue on
but I I don't get to tell them how to
parent their children they parent their
children yeah and and I honestly in my
case
I don't even get to advise not unless
they ask unless they ask yeah my parents
have a situation where they ask I can
ask a lot of questions until they ask
and I've had a couple of them and
different things they were doing
Investments on things and they would say
hey dad would you sit down and be Dave
Ramsey and help us with this I would be
more than honored yeah that's great
thank you that's a that's a huge honor
but I can't go in there and answer
questions that aren't being asked right
and that's the hardest one so at that
point the one of the things that's
helped me Shayna Shanna in that
situation is I have so for the future
decisions that they're all in that
bucket their decisions as adults they're
all in that bucket I uh pretend like
they're my best friend's kids
that's good because you can't use your
best voice on your best friend's kids
you can only use influence
and it helps me step back and go I'm not
in control so I can't use my dad voice I
can I can use it but it won't work
because they just laugh it off they go
he thinks he's in control he's nuts
anymore
so Shannon my son did
um he during he turned 18 during covid
and got interested in investing a little
bit so he started investing in a Roth
and uh Fidelity money market good so
he's got about 3 600 in his Roth and a
little over 8 000 in the money market so
what's your plan for the what's your
plan for these these custodial accounts
that are going to have substantial funds
left in them
it's just more for and and I guess my
son can already go ahead and get to his
the whole thing yes wow and when she's
21 it's his
yeah and actually he'll be 21 in July
it's his that day
um so and you know the great news is is
that you don't have any big worries
because these kids both are seem very
very level-headed and very smart they're
not they're not doing wild and crazy
stuff and that means that you've been
working on these values that they're
carrying for many years
so great job in parenting and uh but be
prepared for little things as they are
out from under your control that you
don't agree with but aren't the end of
the world and
um have the good sense to swallow and
just smile and
um love them right where they are and
they may be they may be doing something
smarter than you they might be doing
something dumber than you but you don't
control it your only control your only
input is influence at that point and as
far as teaching them and guiding them I
always teach young kids little kids all
the way up through uh 90 years old all
of us kids there's three things you can
do with money
give it save it and invest it and enjoy
it and you should always be doing all
three and uh when in doubt hard work is
an awesome antidote to most problems and
if you can remember those three or four
things you are on your way if you're
four years old or you're 94 you can get
through a whole lot of stuff if you're
generous you're continually investing
and um and you're having some fun with
it yeah so just be doing all of that and
give them the uh the Rope links to do
all of those things good show today Jade
well done fun stuff well done well done
Emily Ben James Zach Andrew in the booth
excellent job in there guys that puts
this hour in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey what's up guys it's Jade look if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramsesolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]